Now let's look at the client side. Look
at the ease with which any arbitrary client on
the network can access the server object. What
a client will do is, look up the service
provider, by contacting a boot strap name server
in the Java RMI system. And, it does a
look up of the URL and when it does this look up, so this URL is published,
once it is published, then it can look up this URL. And when it does this look
up of this URL using the facility that's available
in the Java RMI system, then a local access
point for that object is created on the
client side. And so now we've got the access
to the object that is at the server through
this local name account. And once I have that,
then I can do invocations on the methods that
is available in this server object by simply calling those
methods. I can do a deposit. I can do
a withdrawal. I can do a balance check. All of
this, they look like normal procedure calls so far
as the client is concerned. But each of this is
really a call that is going out to the server
wherever that server happens to be, and the Java Runtime
system knows how to locate that server in
order to do this invocation. That's the power of
the Java RMI. The client does not know
and does not care the location of the server.
And if there a failures in any of
these function executions, then remote exceptions will be thrown
by the server through the Java run-time system
back to the client. Of course with the networked
nature of this client/server relationship, if a remote expression
is thrown and the client sees that the invocation
did not succeed, which is a reason the client
saw an exception thrown. It may have no way
of knowing at what point in the invocation the
call actually failed. And this is one of the
problems when you have services that you have to
reach across the network and you have to handle
the exception.